Game of Thrones fans know they need to
be on high alert while watching whether
you're a die-hard fan or casual viewer
it's always fun to hunt for clues with
big importance and the eighth and final
season has provided plenty of them let's
look at some of the tiny details you may
have missed in the last few episodes one
of the first lines spoken in the first
episode of the eighth season comes from
Jon Snow who tells Daenerys northerners
don't blush trust outsiders this becomes
entirely clear when John's sister Sansa
looks skeptical if not downright
contemptuous when faced with the dragon
Queen Daenerys doesn't exactly
ingratiate herself with the northerners
throughout the episode and they remain
unwilling to trust her despite John's
assurances there's plenty of
foreshadowing hear about how Daenerys
and John McFerrin the north once people
learn more about their chosen king not
only was John actually born in Dorne but
he's a highborn and southern heir to the
Iron Throne this makes him an outsider
even though he seems like a northerner
through-and-through
Daenerys was always going to face
opposition but when John's people
learned the truth about his parentage
they might turn on the King in the north
it wouldn't be the first time either in
Game of Thrones his seventh season it
seemed like Cersei Lannister had
something to live for after losing her
three children to poisonings and suicide
she says she's pregnant again and it's a
baby she conceived with her twin brother
Jaime during that moment it seems like
Cersei might start to care about
something other than herself
it's an oddly comforting development
particularly for fans who were worried
that Cersei might turn into a
full-fledged psychopath
Cersei memorably refused a glass of wine
back in season seven but in the season 8
premiere she seemed comfortably sipping
wine after her first night with euron
greyjoy
at one point Greyjoy tells her she
appears to be on the verge of tears as
he walks away perhaps something tragic
happened to the baby since the end of
season 7 but knowing Cersei it's
certainly possible that she made up the
pregnancy in the first place all in an
attempt to get her brothers to side with
her either way that glass of wine seems
significant especially considering the
way she usually hits the bottle when
Qyburn interrupts Bronn at the brothel
on behalf of the Queen viewers know the
reason must be an evil
ever since Circe's brothers Jamie and
Tyrion turned on her she's been out for
revenge and she and Qyburn seem to think
bran is the man to inflict that revenge
well audiences might want to take a
second look at his weapon if that
crossbow looks familiar it's because
it's the exact same weapon Tyrion used
to kill his father Tywin at the end of
the show's fourth season Tim took down
the crossbow in regards to Cersei Qyburn
even tells Bronn that she has a keen
sense of poetic justice that's quite the
understatement it remains to be seen
whether Bronn will ultimately turn on
both his former allies for his own
benefit at the end of the season's first
episode Jon Snow finally learns that
he's the child of Lyanna stark and
rhaegar targaryen which makes him the
true heir to the Iron Throne that's
information we as viewers have known for
a while but Jon's been in the dark this
whole time still there are plenty of
clues about the impending reveal leading
up to that scene throughout the episode
there are several offhand comments about
who Jon really is or who he has become
remember the comments made by young
Lyanna Mormont the lady Liana who's
named after Jon Snow's real mother tells
him he left Winterfell at Kingdom came
back but the biggest moment hinting at
Jon's big reveal is his ride atop a
dragon after all only Targaryen can ride
dragons and Jon rides an especially
significant one while Daenerys takes her
place atop drogon Jon mounts Rhaegar
named for his real father also worth
noting when Sam tells John about his
real heritage the two are standing in
front of Ned Stark statue in Winterfell
scripts remember the last time Jon saw
Ned he made a promise the next time we
see each of them
we'll talk about your mother that makes
it particularly fitting that John learns
the big news with a statue of his
adoptive father at his side Jaime
Lannister's returned to Winterfell was
bound to be a rough one after all the
last time he was there he tried
murdering a young bran Stark after the
boy caught him and his twin sister
Cersei doing things that twins really
aren't supposed to do as if that weren't
bad enough though he's guilty of
murdering Daenerys his father which
earned him the name Kingslayer suffice
to say he doesn't receive a particularly
warm welcome even after his friend
Brienne of Tarth vouches for his
character though he's granted a royal
reprieved by the mother of dragons it
soon becomes clear that he doesn't have
a lot of faith in his new queen and she
is different she is and srivasa I am
keep in mind that Daenerys his father
had a nickname of his own the Mad King
for obvious reasons Jaime has never had
anything good to say about it may the
skin blackened
melted of that bones no wonder he's
distrustful of Daenerys especially
considering her own fondness for fire
if Daenerys is poised to turn into the
mad queen as many fans suspect Jamie
will have been right not to trust her
only time will tell how all that plays
out until then we'll be watching closely
so closely check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Game of Thrones are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]